thwippity thwhip thwhip the time has
come the empire is here to reign
spiderman no way home jazz we have
exclusively covered empire magazine's
exclusive coverage of spiderman no way
home by exclusively commentating on
cosmic warren wonder spider warren's
exclusive coverage and apparently this
week yesterday uh i've just avoided it
specifically for this cosmic wonder week
that we've been having here there's
another video sprinkled in stop saying
all we cover is this there was literally
three uploads in a row that we're not
spyro go check out our squid game fancy
four videos in a row actually our
interview with liam mcqueen go watch
something else i'm gonna miss this
coverage by the time this movie comes
out man this is an awesome journey and
we're just a month and a half till we're
at the freaking finish line crazy it
still feels like forever
i'm excited all right guys let's watch
this and see what warboy has to say
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today the article for empire magazine
officially came out the one that we've
been talking about for about a week now
and with that new article comes four
brand new photos from oh boy new way
home and a little bit of information
about the movie now it's nothing really
really big look how green
so much like the other days of this week
lots of spiderman
today and i'm going to break it all down
and let's start with this one of doc
because i truly think that it is the
most interesting for a few reasons here
one a photo was released yesterday where
doc ock was holding up spider-man now
yesterday he only had two arms holding
him up one was wrapped around him and
the other was holding his head now this
is probably the same scene the
background is a little bit different it
looks like they could be under the
bridge instead of on top of the bridge
but we do see a bridgetown webbed up to
the right of alfredmolinas.org now we've
obviously seen the photo of doc ock
throwing the cars and as i predicted
spider-man was probably running to try
and save some of the cars by webbing
them up and making sure that they don't
fall off the bridge it looks like he was
pretty successful in that part okay so
he wasn't running away just because he
was terrified of doc i was trying to
catch some just how the photo looked yes
we'll see who's right don't slander
spiderman with a bad picture okay but
damn looking at this photo i mean the
saturation on the green is especially
pumped up here way more green than it
appeared because i think there was like
tiny shades of green and spiderman too a
bit a little bit different i don't know
if my memory is just like that or if
that's actually the case right here
though the green color oh that's awesome
that looks great it's green in the
glasses the reflective lighting
green freeway it's a green tree wow so
much green and i've actually been told
something kind of specific about this
photo if you look closely to his arms
you can actually see that he has some
red in his arms now what i've been told
from a source is that these are actually
nanobots and it looks like they could be
from tom holland's nano technology iron
spider suit now that's all
that i can get unfortunately if you do
take a look closely
you kind of look like it could be from
tom holland's nano suit so there are a
lot more questions arise because of this
one
who exactly did this now the question is
that they are bringing villains over
from the sam raymond universe obviously.
these pictures and saw him in the
trailer however just because he's from
the raimi universe doesn't exactly mean
it's the exact same doc ock from
spider-man 2. perhaps he comes from a
timeline where he actually defeated toby
maguire spider-man and he lived and he
went on and perhaps he could have
developed some nanotechnology himself in
fact i actually think it would be pretty
dang cool if his arms were nanotech so
could this be something that doc ock is
doing he does look like he is fully in
control with the red nanotech on his
tentacles but it could also be something
that spider-man tried to do did he try
to deploy some of his suit on doc ock to
try and fight him could he have tried to
put his own nanotech on his tentacles to
try and control the arms because i can
definitely see how that could be a
tactic however judging by this photo i
don't think it's really working okay
wait is the implication what my question
is specifically is he's saying it
absorbed
iron spider nanotech stuff yeah that was
during the middle of the fight because
that's that's the sense i got pretty
extreme to me yeah yeah i mean you per
pep in advance
you would think so i don't know i mean
maybe it's technology that he hasn't
quite seen yet but also has the
capability to assimilate or something
because if you look at that shot of him
holding peter up they don't look as red
in that shot they look more akin to the
you know way they looked in the sam
raimi one so it would appear visually
that maybe it does happen like part way
through the fight or this could be just
a lot of freeway-based action for this
movie i just feel like we gotta let some
of this start tech die it is a start
text that nano attack which probably
comes from starkiller well
that's broken through the nanotech
barrier the most in this world i'm aware
that in some of the comics that his arms
are made of nanobots so it does line up
oh yeah there's plenty of sci-fi
mumbo-jumbo inroads you can take to make
this work iron man invented it first
movie ever to do nano technology and it
is not the answer for every crazy sci-fi
invention ever and not today action
sci-fi movie not now i'm like when will
they get some more nanotech plot lines
geez perhaps doc ock actually takes the
nanotech from his suit and puts them on
his tentacles it's a cool photo
technology
is going to have when he comes into
spider-man no way home but perhaps it
could be pretty advanced and i actually
think this would be a cool initial
encounter doc got kind of just
completely overpowering spider-man to
where he needs some help aka the other
two spider-man now another picture that
we have is of spider-man and it appears
that he is in the basement of the new
york sanctum three things about this
photo that i noticed one is there's
there seems to be sort of two parts to
this basement one part behind him looks
like it has furniture it looks like it's
kind of a lounge area and the part in
front of him where he's standing kind of
looks like it's all made out of rock it
actually looks like the place where
doctor strange does the spell yeah
that's the second thing i noticed but
peter parker is in his spider-man suit
here and when we saw him in the trailer
he was not in a spider-man suit when
doctor strange did the spell this leads
me to believe that this is going to be
after he does the spell and perhaps the
villains could have broken out of the
prison right here this could be after
spider-man and doctor strange fight
because as rumor has it right now doctor
strange and peter fight and that's what
releases the villains i mean it could be
right before that photo where he's on
top of the car that was released earlier
responding on top of the car i mean if
anything it could be right before the
fight they start getting into the
shenanigans yeah i can absolutely see
that pretty soon he'll get punched out
of his body or whatever yeah where it
becomes kind of like a hot potato with
that prison yeah exactly why yeah i mean
i can i can already see the sequence of
like the box dropping and sliding around
and then grabbing it and flying in the
air and the spider-man getting in
magic magic yeah spider-man tries to
thwip it but then he opens up a sling
ring and it goes through with you the
last thing i noticed is the staircase in
the background that staircase is
actually where peter mj and ned were
when we got our very first photo for
spider-man no way home of the three of
them looking up at a mysterious figure
this looks like the exact same place so
the mysterious figure could be doctor
strange however at this point in time
peter probably ran into him already so
could it actually be another spider-man
coming from a different universe that's
something i'm very curious to see
because they want us to believe that
they're looking at doctor strange and
typically when marvel wants us to
believe something it's because it's
something else but
wait and see until the movie comes out
now there's two more photos and there's
not really that much to them to look
into one is of doctor strange he's
standing there with his arms crossed he
has a sling ring in his hand and he has
a cut on the side of his face we can
maybe assume that him and peter just got
done fighting and the villains broke out
and possibly that scratch came from
peter or one of the villains again it's
just a picture of him in front of the
sanctum with his arms crossed which
means he's probably pretty upset about
something so i'm gonna go ahead and say
this is after the fight and after the
villains get out but again it's just a
picture of him standing there so it's
really hard to tell honestly that doctor
strange photo could just be a set photo
while he's getting direction yes
it's like he's listening
okay do it again while they're setting
up a shot it's just a bts yeah yeah no
or he's just really kind of angry and
bored with spiders
and for the last photo we've kind of
seen this before and we know the context
of the situation this is pretty much
right after the events of spider-man far
from post credit scene mj is with peter
and they're very very high it looks like
they were on top of some type of
scaffolding or really big construction
equipment it looks like peter grabbed
him jay and she kind of took off a
little bit but then the helicopter
starts surrounding that cool she's
wearing the exact same suit that he was
in the post credits so far from home and
so is mj she's wearing the exact same
clothes so we pretty much know exactly
what the scene is now like i did mention
empire magazine did talk a little bit
about toby mcguire and andrew garfield
of course they did not confirm anything
they're not going to confirm something
that big in an empire magazine article
but i'll tell you what they said now
first off they did kind of address other
rumors like jamie foxx returning as
elektro and of course sandman and the
lizard returning as well but all they
really said was these are rumors going
around well yeah no kidding their rumors
going around and just saying that their
rumors is not confirming or denying so
it's a great response but it doesn't
tell us anything at all but then they go
and talk about other teams like kristen
dennis possibly returning stone possibly
returning and then they give us this
paragraph and most seismically there
have been reports that holland won't be
the only spider-man in the movie that at
some point the current peter parker will
share a screen with tobey maguire and
andrew garfield the actors who preceded
him in the role we could be looking at a
veritable peck of peter parker
spider-man spider-man's doing whatever
spiders can it goes on to say the way in
which these rumors have blossomed and
mutated has been fascinating to watch
going from mere wishful thinking to
being treated as cold hard fact in
record time there is now an expectation
among spider fans that garfield and
maguire will show up at some point in no
way home first off it sounds like they
brushed past a lot of rumors and then
they exceptionally magnified
one specific set of rumors that would
have to be approved by this article has
to be approved by sony everything that
they are saying in here maybe kind of
throw people off by bringing up some
rumors of things that are likely not
going to occur in the movie let's really
hone in on
[Music]
one let's create a haystack and then
please needle come on yeah i don't feel
like i'm reading into that no this is
all part of the master plan and listen
to what kevin feige says about this
rumors are fun because many of them are
true and many of them are not true the
danger is when you get into the
expectations game of wanting people to
be excited about the movie they get and
not disappointed by a movie they didn't
get to me kevin feige is playing it cool
i mean it's kevin foggy he's the
ultimate cool guy but at this point in
time i've seen enough evidence for
myself and have talked to enough
insiders who have confirmed that both
toby and andrew are in the film that i
fully believe that they are coming in
fact i've been told some pretty specific
details about some scenes that
unfortunately i can't reveal but i love
how kevin feige said rumors are fun
because many of them are true
i would never read too much to what
kevin feige says to me there's
absolutely nothing different
there about kevin feige's code of what
he says about everything and every river
everything he ever gets asked about is
like maybe it is maybe
yeah
but probably not
yeah that's that's the ultimate answer
every fighty answer is you're probably
right unless you're probably wrong
it's like let's say that rumors are
actually damaging that's the best thing
to do is just be like sure maybe
have fun
discuss amongst yourselves you never
know you can say rumors are true yes uh
[ __ ] in the trailer see i told you that
was something that was the one true one
all the rest of her faults they're not
gonna let them talk about it and get
everybody's expectations up just for
them to not be in the movie but let me
know what you think about these new
photos and about this article in the
comments down below
i think nothing
woof nah man that's great stuff dude
especially the whole eye opening thing
about the nano tech wouldn't it doc off
as much as there's rumor of the many
rumors that green goblin is the main
villain i really feel like they're
having us focus primarily on doc ock
yeah we know the mcu a lot of times they
put your attention towards one villain
in the marketing and then you're like oh
this is actually the other one
all of these ox scenes are actually
green goblin scenes with the goblin
painting yeah
all right guys well spiderboard thank
you for covering this and breaking this
down for us and for everything this week
moore and i are actually buddies okay so
he's
really sent me a lot of messages to stop
covering his videos and that it's
getting out of hand and ruining our
friendship and i said
nay
if you haven't done so
hit that like button say hi to jesus
and hey we'll thrip you guys soon